[Musik]
guten abend dem westen der republik von
rheinland pfalz bis in den norden von
nrw begegneten unsere reporterinnen und
reporter heute immer wieder demselben
erschreckten staunen in städten und
dörfern am fluss von familien die seit
generationen mit hochwassern leben und
die immer sagen wir kennen das aber so
war es noch nie
gewiss ist das war und dann gibt es
menschen die sagen mit recht wir haben
es kommen sehen wir waren gewarnt der
wandel des klimas wird sich in solchen
wettern entladen
die bilder und die toten der letzten
nacht und von heute waren demnach auch
folge von versäumnissen über jahrzehnte
versäumnissen der menschheit und ihre
entscheidungen beiden gedanken gehen wir
nach und beginnen dort wo menschen
betroffen waren und sind ein bericht von
susanna santino in altena im sauerland
zeigt sich die zerstörerische gewalt der
enormen regenfälle die gestern begannen
die länder reißt alles mit sich was ihr
in den weg kommt ein 46 jähriger
feuerwehrmann wird von den fluten
mitgerissen und stirbt nachdem er
geholfen hatte einen anwohner zu retten
ein weiterer feuerwehrmann kommt im
einsatz ums leben
und auch viele anwohner sind urplötzlich
in lebensgefahr
wir wollten gestern eigentlich nur eine
oma den strom im keller abschalten und
sind danach selber in eine notsituation
geraten und aus dieser hat uns unser
freund dirk ohne zu zögern und sein
leben aufs spiel gesetzt und uns mit
seinen radlager in einer spektakulären
aktion herausgeholt mindestens 24
menschen sind seit gestern in nordrhein
westfalen ums leben gekommen
überall überschwemmte straßen
überflutete keller und häuser die
innenstadt von bad münstereifel wurde
völlig zerstört
überall in den häusern schlamm von die
brücke hinab gestürzt
was darüber weiter runter sind sogar
heilsam weggekommen
also ist
notstand
zweiter wurde
bei arten kann ein hochwasser dann die
wassermassen des flusses ende nicht mehr
halten
seit dem morgen wird ein
braunkohletagebau geflutet ein
mitarbeiter wird vermisst konnte bis
jetzt nicht gefunden werden
die bundeswehr unterstützt die kräfte
mit 500 soldaten vor ort ohne den panzer
wäre dieser lkw nicht auf den
schlammmassen herausgekommen
in hagen macht sich ministerpräsident
armin laschet ein bild von der lage
kein wort was wir sprechen kann diesen
verlust ersetzen aber dennoch sind die
gedanken wir alle dem was wir jetzt hier
organisieren müssen bei den familien
derer die ums leben gekommen ist sind in
rheinland pfalz kommen mindestens 28
menschen ums leben
in altena fliehen viele vor den
plötzlichen wassermassen auf die dächer
ihrer häuser
diese familie kann gerade noch gerettet
werden
statt den notwendigen aufräumarbeiten
hat jetzt nur eins priorität
menschenleben zu retten
besonders betroffen von dem unwetter ist
der 660 einwohner ort schuld hochwasser
sind sie hier gewöhnt aber so eine
katastrophe sagen sie hat keiner
erwartet
sechs häuser sind hier eingestürzt immer
noch werden 70 menschen vermisst hinter
uns haben zwei häuser gestanden
man sieht ja wie viele häuser kaputt ist
stücks und sie wissen ich will wissen
gar nicht wie es weitergeht ist alles
weg gesprochen alles kaputt halbe mio
schaden du bist nicht was wir machen
sollen
auch die ministerpräsidentin des landes
zeigt sich über die folgen dieses
gewaltigen unwetters schockiert
das ist eine naturgewalt die wir hier
erlebt haben die uns alle sprachlos
macht wir sind traurig weil diese
katastrophe verursacht dass wir den
menschen verloren hat und die
bundeskanzlerin meldet sich aus
washington
meine gedanken sind bei ihnen und sie
können darauf vertrauen dass alle kräfte
unseres staates von bund ländern und
gemeinden gemeinsam alles daransetzen
werden auch unter schwierigsten
bedingungen leben zu retten
mindestens 58 tote dutzende vermisste
und hunderte die ihr gesamtes hab und
gut verloren haben
die vorläufige bilanz dieser katastrophe
wir erreichen jetzt nicht unserem
reporter beach area in rheinland-pfalz
der diesem tag in schuld und in
ahrweiler erlebt hat wir schalten
deshalb gleich nach reinhardswald
entschuldigungen nach nordrhein
westfalen dort im brennpunkt hagen war
tagsüber unser kollege alexander hettich
alexander kann dieses gebet jetzt
wenigstens in ruhe die nacht beginnen
mit all dem was passiert ist
ruhe ist eingekehrt wenn man sich das
hier anschaut was an geröll an trümmern
heruntergekommen ist letzte nacht dann
kann man erahnen wie das hier ausgesehen
hat wie das wasser hier herunter
geräuschen ist die autos hier vorne die
sind nicht nur eingefangen im schlamm
die sind auch voller wasser die werden
in diesem leben wohl nicht mehr fahren
wir haben mit nachbarn gesprochen die
weiter oben wurden den sind die gärten
sozusagen fortgespült worden und was
viel schlimmer ist die wissen gar nicht
ob die statik der häuser noch in ordnung
ist ob die häuser gerettet werden können
all das treibt die menschen hier um
werden mit vielen verzweifelten
besitzern solcher häuser gesprochen
die erwarten nun klarheit werden die
ganze nachgrübeln und sie erwarten nur
hilfe von den behörden von land und
kommune nun ist der haken einer stadt
mit fast 200.000 einwohnern sieht es da
überall so aus wie jetzt im hintergrund
bei ihnen oder gibt es gebiete von
hagens die im grunde
ohne schaden davon gekommen sind nein
wenn man große teile des stadtgebietes
sieht da fällt einem gar nicht auf dass
sie ganz normal aus im stadtzentrum dass
ein paar kilometer weiter unten licht
ich bin in hohenlimburg das ist rang
gelegen im stadtzentrum hat es
überflutungen gegeben auch da sind um
geschäfte und häuser überspült worden
aber die zerstörungen sind nicht so groß
hier an der hanglage hat sich das ganze
besonders übel bemerkbar gemacht und man
fragt sich auch wie man solchen
geschichten solchen katastrophen künftig
vorbeugen will
weil es ist extrem schwierig zu sehen
wie man so etwas verhindern will wenn
solche wassermassen wie gestern
herunterkommen dankeschön alexander es
wird als bild an vielen stellen seien
das schaden und schadlos ganz eng
beieinander liegen
experten sagen uns dass wir jetzt die
auswirkungen des klimawandels erleben
die lange vorhergesagt wurden aber nicht
immer ernst genug genommen wurden um
langfristige entscheidungen zu bestimmen
jetzt ist die entwicklung da benjamin
chudnofsky beschäftigt sich mit diesem
aspekt des geschehens
es sind diese bilder die uns heute
erschrecken die bittere wahrheit ist
aber wohl wir werden uns an sie gewöhnen
müssen es ist so dass in unseren
szenarien rechnungen deutlich führt dass
die schäden im stark steigen werden das
ist im mittel vielleicht eine
verdoppelung oder verdreifachung schon
in der näheren zukunft aber es kann auch
deutlich darüber hinausgehen das hängt
auch davon ab wie die die das klima sich
am ende entwickeln wird die flusspegel
werden weiter steigen
berechnungen der wissenschaftler aus
potsdam haben gezeigt dass durch
stärkere regenfälle in den kommenden
jahren zb in brandenburg achtmal mehr
menschen von hochwasser betroffen sein
werden in niedersachsen zwölfmal mehr
und in baden württemberg sogar 15 mal
mehr menschen als heute
wir sehen auch immer häufiger sehr
intensive niederschläge in zum beispiel
kleine täler das wasser sammelt sich da
die dörfer liegen am auslass dieser
kleinen flüsse dort sammelt sich das
wasser führt dann im zweifel zu sehr
starken sehr schnellen hochwassern die
leute rennen in ihrer tiefgarage
versuchen das auto zu retten und dann
kommt es eben zu willig schlimme dinge
die szenarien scheinen also klar zu sein
die frage ist wie gehen wir damit um
was brauchen zum beispiel unsere dörfer
und städte für die zukunft es ist ein
dreiklang auf der einen seite müssen wir
die kritischen infrastrukturen schützen
es geht darum dass strom das
energieversorgung nicht auskennt in so
einem fall das in obernfeld dass das
krankenhaus noch funktioniert etc
dann gibt es die ebene der anpassungen
korrekturen es geht darum dass wir im
außenraum materialien einbauen die dazu
führen dass sich das schnell in der lage
ist das anfallende wasser aufzunehmen
und das überschuss wasser wenn ich so
die bilder gesehen habe eben durch eine
leistungsfähigere kanalisation abführen
kann dann und es geht dann natürlich
auch um die schadensminimierung menschen
muss jetzt geholfen werden die kommunen
müssen insbesondere auch immer besser
ausgestattet werden um diese aufgaben zu
bewältigen
vieles von dem steht auch in den
wahlprogrammen was es jetzt aber braucht
ist handeln
wir sehen aber an diesen ereignissen die
wir jetzt auch jetzt wieder in
nordrhein-westfalen zum beispiel gesehen
haben dass man den klimawandel am ende
eben nicht aussetzen kann man muss auch
die maßnahmen die man beschlossen hat
auch wirklich umsetzen
so ist das hochwasser in seinem ganzen
schrecken vielleicht auch ein weckruf
für das was kommen kann
professor lamia mazzarri becker ist eine
international angesehene bauingenieurin
und expertin für stadtentwicklung ist
letztes jahr war sie im
sachverständigenrat der bundesregierung
für umweltfragen wir erreichen sie per
internet-video guten abend angesichts
der bilder heute haben wir die wucht der
folgen des klimawandels in unserer
milden ausgeglichenen ecke der welt
unterschätzt guten abend herr kleber ja
der heutige tag ist möglicherweise
möglicherweise der beweis dafür dass wir
die folgen des klimawandels tatsächlich
unterschätzt haben seit mehr als 30
jahren liegen unsere
forschungsergebnisse vor die das
nahelegen das wetter extreme schneller
heftiger häufiger konzentrierter
vorkommen können ich kann natürlich
nicht mit sicherheit sagen dass ob der
fall nicht auch ohne den klimawandel
hätte eintreten können
regen katastrophen gehirn nun mal auch
dazu aber diese katastrophe ist jetzt da
sie ist da und sie trifft auf
begünstigende verhältnisse zu viel
versiegelung zuviel zersiedelung und wir
müssen jetzt handeln klimaanpassung
mindestens so wichtig wie klimaschutz
und das ist ihr spezialgebiet wie müssen
denn die städte der zukunft vorbereitet
werden
auf solche umweltsituation wir brauchen
im prinzip immer ein dreiklang wir
müssen die kritischen infrastrukturen
schützen das heißt konkret wenn so etwas
passiert darf energieversorgung
wasserentsorgung krankenhaus versorgen
etc daran nicht zusammenbrechen da kommt
es darauf an dass die kommunen gut
ausgestattet sind interkommunal also
untereinander kooperieren
dann gibt es natürlich die ebene der
korrekturen also städtebauliche
anpassungen
es geht darum dass im außenraum wasser
versickern kann und dass überschuss
wasser irgendwo abgeführt werden kann es
geht darum dass wir frühwarnsysteme und
auch ad hoc maßnahmen einbauen können
wenn ich aber die bilder sehe dann
verschlägt mir das eigentlich die die
sprache da geht es jetzt weniger darum
ob jetzt im außenband ein material drin
war oder zu wenig grünfläche da war
darum geht's ja nicht hier geht es um
wirklich was größeres wir müssen die
infrastruktur ertüchtigen leistungsfähig
kann
situation haben und es geht auch darum
um am ende um bebauungs fragen wo wollen
wir weiter versuchen weiter bauen wo
müssen wir möglicherweise auch anders
handeln das klingt nach einem fast nicht
mehr zu ermessen infrastrukturprojekt
für die nächsten zehn zwanzig jahre das
ist in der tat so wie gesagt wir müssen
weiter gegen klimawandel kämpfen
klimaschutz betreiben aber die
klimaanpassung ist mindestens so wichtig
wir müssen also auch uns fragen wo sind
die euros besser investiert wo kann ich
noch klimaschutz wo geht es nur noch um
anpassung und da ist die bebauung
natürlich extrem wichtig also wäre ich
jetzt den beitrag richtig verstanden
habe geht es hier weniger darum dass man
irgendwelche flüsse verändert hat die
verläufe der flüsse verändert hat weil
dann konzentrierte sich in konjunktiven
die wassermenge die würde sich auch
beschleunigen das ist ja hier glaube ich
nicht der fall aber die tal lage zum
beispiel die topologie die vergünstigte
günstig natürlich die folgen und da
müssen wir darüber nachdenken wo wollen
wir weiter das so gestalten und wo ist
vielleicht auch rückbau und keine
versiegelung keine zersiedelung mehr
geboten zum schutz der menschen
wenn man heute einige bilder zum
beispiel aus ahrweiler oder aus schuld
sieht diesem ort im aartal der in dem
sich so wunderbar dort hindurch
schlängelt in mehreren schlaufen der ort
der heute fast völlig verwüstet ist kann
es im extremfall bedeuten dass wir
einige unserer schönsten gegenden
wohngegenden aufgeben müssen ich hoffe
nicht aber ich befürchte wir müssen uns
mit dieser frage auch befassen
wo können wir noch diese schutzmaßnahmen
die ich erläutert happ halbwegs
hinkriegen und dann auch den mehrwert
sehen dass wir wirklich einen schutz
gewährleisten können und wo geht es
nicht mehr und wenn ich die bilder sehe
glaube ich dass die bebauung der zukunft
ganz bestimmt nicht darin liegt überall
zu bauen wo es gerade passt und wo man
gerade will
nein wir müssen auch wieder schauen
welche abstände müssen wir einhalten
welche strukturen lassen wir zu und
welche müssen wir korrigieren ja da bin
ich ganz bei ihnen die frage muss
gestellt werden darum geht's folgen des
klimawandels
vor 30 oder mehr jahren programmiert
worden ist und sich jetzt vielleicht
nicht mehr steuern lässt dankeschön
professor michael becker ich danke ihnen
im journal update um 0.30 spricht da
sein guckte mir über lehren aus diesen
katastrophen tag mit klimaforscher fred
hatte man vom potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung nachrichten von
gundula gause beginnt mit einem termin
der heute normalerweise noch deutlich
mehr aufmerksamkeit bekommen hätte bei
ihrem abschiedsbesuch in washington ist
bundeskanzlerin merkel zur stunde im
gespräch mit us-präsident beiden es geht
um die wiederbelebung der deutsch
amerikanischen beziehungen und um
lösungen für verschiedene konflikte wie
den kurs gegenüber china oder dem streit
um handelszölle geplant sind foren zur
entwicklung gemeinsamer strategien
zuvor war kanzlerin merkel die
ehrendoktorwürde der john hopkins
universität verliehen worden
und auch bei dem gespräch mit
vizepräsident in harris waren
geopolitische herausforderungen thema
der bekannte niederländische kriminal
reporter peter de vries ist mehr als
eine woche nach dem auf ihn verübten
attentat seinen schweren verletzungen
erlegen das gab seine familie bekannt
der fries war in amsterdam
niedergeschossen und lebensgefährlich
verletzt worden er hatte immer wieder
über organisierte kriminalität richtet
zuletzt war der 64-jährige
vertrauensperson eines kronzeugen in
einem drogenprozess zwei tatverdächtige
des mordanschlages sind in
untersuchungshaft
der streit zwischen der eu und warschau
um die polnische justizreform verschärft
sich der europäische gerichtshof hat die
disziplinar regeln für richter in polen
als unvereinbar mit eu-recht eingestuft
die unabhängigkeit der justiz sei
bedroht aus warschau kommt schroffe
ablehnung dahinterstehe koloniales
denken
inzwischen hat sich die delta variante
des corona virus auch in deutschland
stark ausgebreitet
anfang juli wiesen laut robert koch
institut bereits drei von vier
untersuchten proben die mutation auf
ein grund dafür dass die
infektionszahlen wieder steigen
das rk registrierte innerhalb eines
tages 1642 neue fälle das sind 672 mehr
als vergangenen donnerstag die sieben
tage ins ident stieg auf 8,0
in einer bewegenden trauerfeier hat
spanien seiner mehr als 81.000
todesopfer der pandemie gedacht im
mittelpunkt stand auch die ehrung von
mitarbeitern des spanischen
gesundheitssystems 102 sanitäter pfleger
und ärzte hatten sich bei der behandlung
von patienten angesteckt und waren an
cupid 19 gestorben
sie würdigte könig felipe posthum mit
zivildienst orden und mahnte zugleich
die pandemie sei noch nicht zu ende
hoffnung gebe dass impfen das
filmfestival in cannes will auch an
einem tag wie diesem ernst genommen
werden einem tag an dem es um themen
geht den deren angesetzt die glitzer und
glamour die ganze scheinwelt eines
solchen festivals unpassend wäre
eigentlich die filmwelt versucht eine
antwort zu geben mit ihren mitteln und
manchmal gelingt dass sabine schulz ist
für uns dort aus aller welt sind sie
angereist an die 30.000 festivalbesucher
sollen es dieses jahr sein
corona bedingt weniger als sonst dafür
kommen diesmal im juli die touristen
dazu hollywood-größen die für einen tag
einfliegen und wieder zurück wie
vertretbar ist ein filmfestival in
zeiten des klimawandels
[Musik]
wir sind uns der dringlichkeit des
klimawandels bewusst und dass wir nicht
ewig so weitermachen können zum beispiel
muss der festivalbesucher ab sofort mit
einer abgabe seine co2 fußabdruck
kompensieren
und es gibt eine neue sektion cinema
pole klima kino fürs klima mario cotillo
etwa hat einen dieser klima filme
unterstützt und produziert der
dokumentarfilm bkw nass erzählt von
jugendlichen aus aller welt die über
sich hinauswachsen
wir haben den viele vier jahren begonnen
bevor alle von kreta thunberg sprachen
aber das engagement junger leute für die
umwelt und gegen den klimawandel war
schon da wir wollten den blick auf die
18 jährige melanie aus indonesien kämpft
gegen die plastik flut seit sie zwölf
jahre alt ist
sie hatte bewegung bei bei plastiktüten
gegründet heute haben wir in nur einer
stunde siebeneinhalb kilo müll am strand
gesammelt wir haben tonnenweise plastik
gesammelt aber unser größter erfolg ist
dass wir andere junge leute an 60 orten
rund um die welt inspiriert haben auch
ihren ländern solche bei plastiktüten
gruppen zu bilden und bali hat auf
unseren druck hin einwegplastikflaschen
ganz verboten
[Musik]
der film schickt mir lahti auf eine
reise rund um die welt auf der sie
andere junge aktivistinnen trifft sie
engagieren sich für klimaschutz bildung
oder frauenrechte
es ist das porträt einer neuen
generation die vollen einsatz bringt wir
sind nicht mehr aufzuhalten und wir
warten nicht auf die erlaubnis um zu
handeln
wir ziehen das zusammen durch und sie
wissen die bühne von cannes zu nutzen
ein zeichen der hoffnung ein anfang
nicht mehr aber auch nicht weniger
die nachrichten aus der wirtschaft
kommen nun auf finanzielle folgende
ereignisse die die letzten 24 stunden
bei uns beherrscht haben die schweren
regenfälle haben nicht nur in
deutschland sondern auch in anderen
teilen westeuropas massive hochwasser
schäden angerichtet das ausmaß der
zerstörung ist noch nicht abzuschätzen
wird aber immens sein
wir fragen frank bethmann welche
finanziellen hilfen für betroffene sind
denn realistisch neben den
unterstützungen von bund und ländern
kommt es natürlich auch darauf an wie
isst man versichert welche
versicherungen greifen überhaupt in
welchen fällen der gesamtverband der
deutschen versicherungswirtschaft mit
dem wir vorhin noch sprachen äußerte
sich sein natürlich noch zu früh über
das ausmaß der schäden oder über die
chance leistungen der versicherung etwas
zu sagen was man aber sagen kann eine
universal versicherung gegen
unwetterschäden wie diese gibt es nicht
entscheidend sind jetzt die
wohngebäudeversicherung sie kommt für
schäden am haus auf die
hausratversicherung sichert schäden an
gegenständen wie möbeln oder technischen
geräten ab und die kfz-versicherung
schäden am auto allerdings ist zu
beachten bei überflutungen und
hochwasser schäden muss es eine
gebäudeversicherung sein die diese
sogenannten elementarschäden
mitversichert mit diesem zusatz baustein
sind bundesweit aber gerade mal 46
prozent aller wohngebäude versichert
unwetterschäden an immobilien sind also
in vielen fällen nicht abgedeckt oft
auch weil versicherungen häusern
risikolagen gar nicht oder nur sehr
teuer versichert für die
versicherungsbranche ist seit langem
klar die schäden durch
klimaveränderungen wachsen stetig so
zeichnet sich bereits jetzt ab dass sich
dieses jahr mit stürmen überschwemmungen
und starkregen zu einem der
kostspieligsten seit 2013 entwickeln
könnte frank bethmann vielen dank
muslimischen mitarbeiterinnen kann das
tragen von kopftüchern verboten werden
mit diesem urteil hat der europäische
gerichtshof die rechte von arbeitgebern
gestärkt sie dürften das tragen jeder
sichtbaren ausdrucksform politischer
oder religiöser überzeugungen verbieten
um kunden ein bild der neutralität zu
vermitteln oder um soziale konflikte zu
vermeiden
hintergrund waren zwei fälle aus
deutschland einer mitarbeiterin einer
kita und eines drogeriemarktes die am
arbeitsplatz kopftuch tragen wollten
fünf jahre nach dem gescheiterten
putschversuch in der türkei hat
präsident erdogan bei einer gedenkfeier
der opfer des 15
juli gedacht erdogan sprach von einem
sieg des volkes und des nationalen
willens mitglieder der türkischen armee
hatten 2016 versucht die regierung zu
stürzen
mehr als 270 menschen kamen dabei ums
leben
gegen angebliche anhänger der
putschisten geht die türkei seit jahren
vor offiziell wurden 321 tausend
menschen verhaftet etwa 3000 zu
lebenslangen haftstrafen verurteilt
das war es von unseren tag an dem die
gewalt der natur und die folgen
menschlichen handelns und nichthandelns
mindestens 58 menschen das leben
gekostet hat da wünschen wir ihnen noch
einen friedlichen abend und eine ruhige
nacht hier geht es weiter mit maybrit
illner und ihren gästen unter anderem
den ministerpräsidenten von nordrhein
westfalen und kanzlerkandidaten der
union dass gleich nach den wie der
wichtigen wetteraussichten bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das klimatologische mittel
für einen juli niederschlag beträgt
ungefähr die hälfte dessen was da
innerhalb von 24 stunden hier im westen
mit 150 liter regen pro quadratmeter
zusammen gekommen ist die gute nachricht
heute aber ist das tief bernd das
verabschiedet sich jetzt und macht platz
für das hoch dana und so werden wir
besonders im westen und im norden
deutschlands am wochenende häufig die
sonne sehen können heute nacht
allerdings haben wir es noch mit dem
tief bern zu tun und dauerregen droht
auch noch einmal allerdings wirklich nur
am alpenrand im allgäu können bis morgen
früh noch mal 60 bis 80 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammenkommen
sonst gibt es einige schauer oder kurze
gewitter und die temperaturen dazu
sinken auf 18 grad an der ostsee und bis
11 grad am alpenrand morgen liegen dann
die höchsttemperaturen ihren nordosten
bei 27 bis 29 grad sonst bleibt es bei
18 bis 24 grad kühler und morgen können
wir die sonne sehen zum beispiel hier an
der donau oder auch am niederrhein im
emsland und an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee
sonst entwickeln sich hier und da einige
regenschauer und gewitter aber die haben
wohl kein unwetterpotenzial näher und in
den nächsten tagen geht es mit gewittern
weiter am samstag im osten am sonntag
aber wirklich nur noch hier in
südostbayern so beruhigt sich das wetter
also zum wochenende